hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and as many of you know i'm a physicist
by training
and occupation and the kinds of physics
i do
right cosmology relativity gravitation
space time particle physics field theory
all this stuff
sometimes goes under the name
fundamental physics
it's a somewhat contentious name because
fundamental sounds
more important and that's not what it's
supposed to mean at one point in my life
i tried to start a campaign to rename
fundamental
physics elementary physics because
elementary sounds a little bit less
pretentious and it's about
the same idea that's the underlying
stuff right the most fundamental bottom
layer stuff out of which everything else
is made
anyway that never caught on that never
does catch on changing names is very
hard
fundamental physics is what we call it
as many of you know fundamental physics
is in a weird
phase right now in some sense it's a
little bit stuck
not completely stuck but let's say
progress is slower than it used to be
in some sense that's because we were
spoiled by the first half of the 20th
century where
we invented quantum mechanics and
relativity and found the expanding
universe and it was just an amazing
change every decade so maybe now we're
in a more natural state of being but
still
we long for the good days when we could
revolutionize physics
every so often and right now our
theories are just too good we have
standard models of gravity of particle
physics of cosmology
and they fit a wide variety of data
under that kind of circumstance
how do you make progress how do you move
forward so i can think of no one better
to talk to about these kinds of
questions than today's guest
frank wilcheck who's a professor of
physics at mit
nobel prize winner back when he was a
graduate student he helped understand
quantum chromodynamics and the
phenomenon called asymptotic freedom
that's what he won the nobel prize for
but since then he's done many other
interesting things on the higgs boson
he co-invented the particle called the
axion which is still hypothetical but
might be out there
uh he invented a new kind of particle
called
anions which can exist in two plus one
dimensions
he's the pioneer of time crystals a
whole bunch of other things
and frank has a very specific very
grounded point of view on fundamental
physics he
wants to push it forward in interesting
ways but he worries that it's become a
little bit
separated disjointed from the data the
experiment the phenomena
on the ground and that's not because you
know he's just
uh crotch the old man getting grumpy
about the kids today
he's very willing to think about black
hole information
the multiverse the anthropic principle
but at the end of the day he wants to
account for what we see and he worries i
think with some good reason
that if you lose sight of that prize you
can sort of
wander out in the wilderness without
making substantial progress
easy to say of course so how do you make
substantial progress well
that's a good question and we'll talk
about that too so frank has a new book
out
called fundamentals it's about you know
it's a very popular level book
accessible to everyone about all the big
ideas in physics
and we talk about in this podcast both
what those ideas are
and then maybe how we can move beyond
them if we can't just speculate
what is the right way to make progress
nobody has any easy answers there but
there are some hot takes there's some
saucy opinions given in this podcast so
i think you'll like it let's go
[Music]
frank wheelchair welcome to mindscape
podcast it's good to be here
so yeah here in some virtual sense of
course like i haven't actually seen
anyone in person to do a podcast in for
for many months now but uh in our minds
exactly locality
um speaking of which you've written a
new book called fundamentals 10 keys to
reality and i thought that would be just
a good
uh theme for a podcast interview because
obviously
fundamental physics is something we both
care a lot about
uh try to push forward but it's also
you know something that is uh in a fun
funny situation right now and so i
thought i would just
start with your opinions about you know
the use of the word
fundamentals like some people don't want
to call certain kinds of physics
fundamental and not
others you know how do you how do you
conceptualize what that means to say
fundamentals well i guess i'm in favor
of a broad interpretation
uh although you know it it varies with
context of course
uh so but as far as calling
things fundamental or not within physics
uh
i think it's fair to call things like
the second law of thermodynamics pretty
fundamental
or emergent phenomena
that uh don't in principle could be
explained from more basic principles
can if they're sufficiently wide ranging
non-obvious uh they just i
i don't begrudge them the label
fundamental
but on the other you know if if you say
what you mean by fundamental
uh and if by fundamental you mean
things that can't be deduced from other
things
that's also a legitimate use of the word
and sometimes handy
so i you know depend as long as
to me it's it's not so much the word but
uh the meaning in context
uh how it's of of it yeah and i think
you probably have more credibility on
this issue than many people since you've
done
both fundamental particle physics but
also work in condensed matter physics
and
and more complex systems yeah and
uh and i'm proud of both and i
uh i do not have
the uh well i i don't have the prejudice
that
that uh things in physics that in
principle could have derived
or or otherwise that could have been
derived from more basic principles
in principle uh don't somehow are
lesser doesn't make them more important
right
no not at all and uh in fact
[Music]
right now uh we have a pretty good
account
pretty good understanding of uh
fundamentals that are necessary
to explain chemistry biology
uh almost all of astrophysics and so
forth and
and i think also a great challenge
understanding how
mind emerges from matter and to me
uh trying to add to those principles is
certainly
and get them from more basic
foundations is a worthwhile enterprise
but i don't think it
it is uh in any
sense more privileged or better
than uh than the great enterprise of
getting on with it so to speak
any more than uh the stud take another
exam
an example which i in geometry uh
there are attempts to develop new
systems of geometry
or to uh to discover new theorems
and at the frontiers of well-developed
subjects
like algebraic geometry or algebraic
topology
and so forth and so on and i don't think
that that kind of activity
is any less basic than the
uh examination of whether you could get
by with fewer axioms
you know on the contrary when a subject
becomes mature
then it's not so interesting to look for
fewer axioms anymore
you know the growth point is not that
the growth point
is the exuberant flourishing
of a structure that that's very rich
already there's an obvious question that
i haven't quite figured out how to ask
but you know maybe you can just answer
whatever you
uh feel is best so for the people out
there who are not physicists
what are the fundamental laws of physics
how do you
you know this is a several hour lecture
i know but how do you summarize it
well uh you wrote a book about it i did
you
and you wrote and you wrote a t-shirt
about it uh
the fundamental laws of physics as we
understand them today are
pretty well encoded in what's called the
standard model or the core
uh which includes as uh
includes a a framework in which you
state the laws
which include which involves relativity
and quantum mechanics
and i don't in the case of relativity i
know what the
i could state stated axiomatically and
quantum mechanics was a little more
tricky to say exactly what the axioms
are but
okay we know in practice well enough
yeah and uh then there are
four forces and a small number of forces
and a small number of ingredients and
you can write down very compact
equations
that as far as we can tell are
an accurate description of all
the uh uh behavior
that we've that is uh simple enough to
study that that we can
and and fully document that we've
observed
that you know the interactions among
elementary particles or
interactions that are simple to analyze
in cosmology and astrophysics uh
and that's it so you can write you yeah
i can tell i could in principle write a
computer program that that has
these laws i could explain it to a
computer and
that that's the fundament those are the
fundamental laws right now
maybe this is a good uh jumping off
point for
what i thought would be you know much
later the conversation but um
the fact that we know so much this core
theory that i've made t-shirts of you
you're the one who
labeled it the core how do you express
this
this amazing fact that if you if you
care about biology or psychology or
something like that
we know the laws of physics we're not
going to discover new particles new
forces that are relevant
to biology uh that's hard to get across
to people who say well there's a lot of
things we don't know so how do you know
how do how do i know what how do i know
that those are those laws are good
enough
yeah uh well it's hard to
you know can't be absolutely sure but
what
uh what is true is that these laws have
been
uh checked tested uh as vigorously
as people know how in very extreme
circumstances
at high energies at low temperatures
with great sensitivity and people
have high motivations to try to find
deviations there'll be nobel prizes and
all kinds
you know all kinds of glory uh but so
far
they've stood up to uh to all these
tests
now this is all in the framework of the
program of i guess you could call
reductionism of saying that
uh we if we understand the laws as they
act
between a few simple objects then we can
build up
mathematically through a description of
more complicated things
in principle there could be forces that
involve many bodies at once or
uh or are outside the framework of
quantum mechanics
uh in principle you know it's it's
the evidence is empirical that it works
yeah
yeah and and and it seems
very it's been tested so exact so
precisely
and so under such extreme conditions
on such a variety of conditions that it
easily encompasses the degree of
accuracy
and the domain of conditions that one
encounters
in chemistry biology and
most almost all of astrophysics uh
and in fact all known astrophysics and
yeah well you know it's so at some point
uh the burden of proof is on some uh
to uh to show how it doesn't work
right now there are plenty of loose ends
there are definitely things we don't
know
and i'm sure we'll come to discuss those
but but
none of them as far as i can tell
seem likely to affect
uh biology even psychology
right uh how the mind we
uh or chemistry or or astrophysics
geophysics or any any
any branch of engineering uh
it seems unlikely that that
significant changes in that in those
equations are going going significant
enough to change the applications are
going to occur
now more than ever there's no reason to
ever stop learning
and the great courses plus makes it easy
and fun
the great courses plus is a streaming
service that gives you
access to thousands of video and audio
courses from top experts in the fields
from the great courses on topics like
build a better financial plan
control stress all the way to playing
guitar like a pro
you might enjoy for example the course
nuclear physics explained
which goes into nuclear physics at the
practical level fission
fusion and the future of power sources
but also as a theoretical physicist
understanding quarks and gluons and how
they come together
to make protons neutrons and atoms
whether you want to take a deep dive
into a subject or learn a little bit of
everything
the great courses plus has something for
everyone so sign up for the grade
courses plus and find out what your
purpose is this year
visit this special url the
greatcoursesplus.com
mindscape to get 14 days of unlimited
access
for free you don't want to pass this up
so go now to th
e great courses plus dot com
slash mindscape have you ever played
around i mean i know i know i have and
i've sort of failed
with trying to modify uh
the standard model or quantum field
theory in some way that
there be new forces that arise when
matter arranges itself in certain
complex ways like you know that
sort of try to make a little bit more
careful the idea of some kind of strong
emergence
yeah well it's sort of been on
my agenda for a long time but it's one
of those things i never
really get around to uh
you know we we work as you know in the
in the context of effective field theory
and
then you can discuss uh effects that
uh involve many many bodies at once that
that do not succumb to this program
of reduction where you study you build
up from
interactions involving just a few bodies
and and
and that's sufficient now we have a
rationalization an
understanding of how that could work in
terms of the
successive interactions among many
bodies getting systematically smaller
drastically than the interactions the
fundamental interactions among
small numbers of particles uh but maybe
that breaks down at some level
and maybe there are 27 body interactions
exactly that somehow kick in or
10 to the 27 body interactions that
somehow
kick in and and the the the
drastic decrease with number of
particles somehow reverses
uh so that's the most concrete idea i've
had along those lines
but if the laws break down i would be
very surprised if that's the way they
break down
it's true it's true it's hard to imagine
that now of course
another thing that's more or less
plausible and
you can play with is uh
interactions that uh like gravity
build up from being very small uh
because they're long range and and
additive
uh like gravity they could build up and
i mean not only have i played with that
i think that those are quite plausible
axions give you something like that but
uh
people have you know you there's
constraints on how powerful those
effects can be
people have looked for so-called fifth
forces and so far
uh come up empty and so so again uh
they are highly constrained and seem
unlikely to affect any practical
application
yeah i mean it's an amazing fact about
the theory as we currently understand it
on the one hand
you know there's the four forces you
mentioned right the weak force
strong force electromagnetism gravity um
on the one hand it looks like kind of a
mess
there's various forces doing various
things there's a difference between
right-handed and left-handed particles
but on the other hand it's
it's quite compact compared to the scope
of what it
is attempting to explain or account for
i
mean
should we should we count the core
theory as simple or as complicated
well it's both uh but i think we
understand
or have a good uh guess
about how that happened if you look at
the four forces
uh at short distances it seems that a
lot of the complications and the
apparent differences between the forces
melt away they come to look very much
more like each other
certainly the three of the four look
very much like each other
they're all mediated by photon like
particles gluons w bosons and so forth
which which have the same sort of are
governed by the same sort of principles
in remarkable detail and even the
strength of the different interactions
comes together
if you extrapolate the known laws to
high enough
to small enough distances so that's
that's on the one hand a lot of these
complications melt away if you go to
short distances
on the other hand we understand that uh
as you go to long distances from
simplicity
uh complications can set in due to
uh what we call symmetry breaking the
roughly speaking
uh and you know this but but for the
audience condensation
condensations occur that
can muck up the law muck up the
appearance of the laws
and so from an underlying simplicity uh
if you
view if you can't get to look at the
what's going on at very small distances
it can look much more complicated
and that thought uh
works out remarkably well certainly in
the weak interaction where there's an
abundance of evidence for symmetry
breaking
and the strong interaction where there's
an abundance of uh
understanding of confinement and other
and symmetry breaking also
uh and so we we know of mechanisms that
we
we have a lot of evidence for this
general picture
and the unification of forces at small
distances works
pretty darn well so i think it's both
simple and complicated it's simple
fundamentally so to speak at short
enough distances
but uh its own internal logic
tells you that it could look and in fact
it does look
more complicated uh phenomenologically
uh when you view it at long distances so
it's it's the complexity emerges
i guess is the the two cent two-word
summary of
yeah complexity emerges from simplicity
is the four-word summary
and like i can imagine that when when
this is first put together the standard
model in you know the
the early 70s obviously you were a major
player here
uh it was it must have just been
overwhelmingly
compelling to say well this idea of
unifying all the forces and simple
structures
is so good let's keep doing it and and
we tried to do that with grand
unification but
we haven't found the evidence for it yet
i mean are you i know that you're a fan
of the idea of grand unification have
you has your has your
uh bayesian prior waivered a little bit
what was was that my bayesian
yeah have you decreased your credences a
little bit well
i think i think the general art i think
there are some very strong
general conclusions that that that uh
or circumstantial evidence pieces of
circumstantial evidence that support
this
view uh there's first of all the primary
fact that
all the forces are governed by
mathematically very similar structures
page gage theories uh and then if you
examine
in detail the uh particles that actually
exist
uh they fit together in into a
unif uh structure that uh allows you to
imagine
that all these theories that are
actually all these apparently different
forces at long distances
actually represent one unified
force uh at small distances where all of
them
become equal and are on the same footing
and are all symmetric with each
other that is not at all automatic it
requires
uh very strong conspiracies among the
different
particles that as to their quantum
numbers as to how they behave under
these different interactions
if it were different then you couldn't
put them together
so that's circumstantial evidence the
other circumstantial evidence is that
if uh apparently the couple as we see
them the coupling strengths are very
different
but if you extrapolate to short
distances
or high energies again to get to the
basics stripping away
complications uh they appear to become
numerically equal
it's to pretty good accurate and so
though that's two and
then uh there's another another
aspect of that is that at the scale at
which they come together
where things you know sort of where the
the veil is lifted
and you should see the ultimate
simplicity you find that gravity also
which appears to be very very different
than strength
is approximately the same so i think we
have strong
encouragement from nature to think along
these lines
uh one last piece of evidence is more
complicated to explain
which is that uh neutrinos have been
discovered
been found to have small but non-zero
masses so much
sort of anomalously small compared to
all other masses
that are not zero and that can be
understood
in in terms of these unified theories
where
uh tiny effects that come from short
distances trickle down to give neutrino
masses
uh but uh it would otherwise appear very
mysterious
so to make the boiled all that down into
a couple of sentences
there are many aspects of our scattered
theories within the
core that appear to be
anomalous or lopsided or somehow
unsatisfactory that become much
more uh ideal much more in the platonic
sense much more beautiful
in this larger framework now there's
one piece of evidence one piece that's
missing here that's really tantalizing
which is the
besides the small neutrino mass is kind
of the other new prediction
that's not just aesthetic and well
not just numerical i don't i don't know
i don't know why we say just numerical
numerical is pretty impressive
the uh of the unification the the
uh is is but a
spectacular new phenomena that's
promised by these unified theories
is uh the decay of protons or
violation of baryon number we say and uh
people have looked very hard for that
and so far they haven't found it
and uh our only answer is well maybe you
haven't looked hard enough
so and you know it it the the
limits are not uh powerful enough to
to really decisively rule out the
picture but but
it certainly would be better to have
positive evidence on that front and that
would that would really to me
uh lock it up so that there's one
missing piece
that that we need to define
i know a lot of people who think along
these lines are also fans of super
symmetry as an extra ingredient that we
haven't seen evidence for
and i think that probably for the people
out there listening they might
not quite understand the distinction
between super string theory and super
symmetry and things like that so what is
your
attitude towards the current state of
that idea okay well supersymmetry
makes this unification of couplings
work better quantitatively so that's
uh that's i was hoping that we would see
supersymmetry at the lhc maybe explain
to us what it is
because watch that maybe explain what it
is what super symmetry is for the people
so super symmetry is uh
an extension of the idea of
uh well you can phrase it in various
ways
uh but maybe the nicest way to phrase it
is it's an extension of the idea
of uh space time to include
not only the ordinary kind of dimensions
of space and time that we're familiar
with
uh that are based on numbers that
satisfy x times y
equals y times x but into what are
called quantum dimensions
that are uh that are
uh governed by numbers that satisfy x
times y equals minus y
times x now this sounds very mystical
and at this level that level it is
but it turns out that if you
want to unite two big classes of
two kingdoms of particles that people
know about so-called fermions and bosons
or more generally if you want to
consider
making symmetries that relate particles
of different spin
you have to go beyond the framework of
ordinary
space and time and it turns out that
it's very difficult to do that in a
mathematically consistent way
but uh using these quantum dimensions is
one way you can do it
so you have motions in space and time
and and
boosts in space and time special
relativity that relates to space and
time
and uh the natural extension of that and
really the only one that's
that's known how to do it
is uh is to add these quantum dimensions
and then
if you uh if you do that though
you need to account for what happened to
particles when they move into these
quantum dimensions
and they don't change where they are
because they're in
in in the sense of space and time
because uh those are the ordinary
dimensions
if you move into the quantum directions
what happens is you change
into a different kind of particle that
has
a different spin a different character
so
if it's a force or boson particle it
turns into a substance or fermion
particle
and vice versa and a different mass but
many of the same properties many of the
same electric charge the same
color charges the same kind of behavior
under weak interactions
all the standard all the basic
interactions of the standard model
are common between uh these particles so
these are called super partners
and they are the price you have to pay
if you want to have super symmetry
you have because no no
no particles with the requisite
properties have been
uh observed no no particle that we
have actually observed has a candidate
super partner
that it could that it could have be is a
candidate for what happens to it when it
moves in super space
uh nevertheless uh it's just as we think
about higher symmetries that are
obscured by
uh condensates as we talked in
talked about in our earlier uh
discussion uh here too you apply the
same idea that there
that the underlying supersymmetry at
short distances is hidden from us
by spontaneous breaking of the symmetry
uh
so that the basic laws would have this
feature but
uh they're obscured from from view
and then it becomes a question of how
obscured how like
how heavy are these particles and
again because the detailed
considerations
indicate that if we want to preserve
this wonderful
improvement in how the couplings unify
they the new particles shouldn't be too
heavy
and some of us were optimistic some of
us were
not me some of us were super optimistic
that uh that that they would be light
enough to be observed at uh
at the large hadron collider that
is still not completely ruled out but
certainly
the most straightforward searches uh
have not
found evidence for any of these
particles
now you know the data is very
complicated and difficult to analyze so
it may be that
it's somehow hiding in the data but
more likely in my view is either that
supersymmetry it's just the whole idea
the whole
line of thought is somehow flawed or the
particles are much or
the particles are uh just a little too
heavy
to to have been observed at the lhc
unfortunately and
it would take a bigger and better
collider to
start producing them yeah i mean maybe
you can opine on this but
the way that i like to say it is we
could in the space of all possible
worlds that we live in only one of them
we could have found supersymmetry
already at the lhc very easily but the
fact that we haven't doesn't mean it's
not there
it's maybe it's less likely that it's
there but it's easy
also to imagine theories where
supersymmetry is real we just haven't
seen it yet
right so uh supersymmetry
as i said there have to be for
supersymmetry to be valid
there have to be these super partner
particles that are the particles that
the particles we know about turn into
when they move into soup
into the quantum dimensions uh but
we don't know what their masses are we
know some of their properties but not
their masses
and they could be very heavy if they're
very very heavy
we lose the benefit of uh
improving the benefit that supersymmetry
would otherwise give in improving
how the couplings unify uh but
okay that that may maybe that's
maybe that was a cruel joke on the part
of nature
i want to think not but but uh the
alternative is that they're just a
little bit too heavy
to have been produced easily and
identified easily at the lhc and we just
have to work a little bit harder
and spend a little more money yeah a
little more scale of the national debt
to uh to uh to
to make bigger and better accelerators
and do bigger and better searches
i should say another another aspect of
this is that uh
many implementations of supersymmetry
produce a candidate for the dark matter
uh
usually called neutrolino neutralino
and that people have searched also very
hard for that
and have not found it yeah uh
so that's also somewhat discouraging
although that's
that's even more indirect i would say
because
there are cosmological considerations
that come in
and the abundance might just be smaller
than is necessary to produce the dark
matter or the particles might not be
stable after all
on cosmological scales there are many
outs for that
uh but nevertheless i mean it was a past
it was something that might have been
observed and hasn't
so yep there it is there it is
and maybe it's also worth mentioning um
something that i think
focuses the attention of a lot of
particle theorists
in this era which is the hierarchy
problem the this
mismatch apparently between the energy
scale of the weak interactions and the
higgs boson
versus the energy scales of grand
unification and gravity i think that for
a lot of us
definitely for me even without a
specific solution to that problem
in mind that was a big motivation for
thinking that when the lhc turned on
we'd see a bunch of new particles one
way or the other
well uh i did not
really share that intuition
uh if to me the likely alternatives were
either super symmetry
showed up or something close to minimal
which is it's turned out to be very
close to minimal
implementation with just a higgs
particle and nothing else
uh but we'll see will
i i still would be hopeful that uh at
somewhat higher energies supersymmetry
would come roaring in and
lots of stuff but well i don't know how
much you want to enter into the
technicalities probably not very much
but probably not very much by doing
the smallness of uh radiative
corrections of various kinds especially
cp violation
uh indicated that a pretty close to
minimal structure
or else a highly symmetric structure
were the only consistent possibilities
right phenomenologically yeah if you
need to hire people and you're using
anywhere other than
indeed you're probably wasting your time
indeed.com is the hiring site that helps
you find
quality candidates with indeed instant
match
indeed searches through millions of
resumes in their database to help show
you the great candidates
instantly so you can do the part you
really need faster
meeting and hiring great people unlike
some sites indeed gives you
full control and payment flexibility
delivering a quality
short list faster and with indeed there
are no long-term contracts you can pause
your account at any time
and only pay for what you need with
instant match you see a list of great
candidates with
zero weight and indeed delivers four
times
more hires than all other job sites
combined
if you want your quality shortlist fast
you need indeed right now
our listeners get a free 75 credit to
upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape this is indeed's best offer
anywhere get a free
75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through march 31
terms and conditions apply
i mean so i guess i wonder your your
feeling on
how big the hierarchy problem is as a
problem so just to just let people know
you know we have the
mass of the higgs boson which is a
certain number and then we have the
planck scale or the grand unification
scale way way bigger than that
and to many of us this is a mystery but
other people
think well you know it's just a number
we measured it it's not a mystery at all
so
is this a motivating feature of the data
for you well
yeah it well it's it's a motivation but
it's a very broad motivation and to me
it's kind of been superseded
by this unification of couplings which
is
much more quantitative and sort of a
much more positive clue
so no the hierarchy problem i think they
they go together but to me the
unification of couplings is stronger
right i think it's as a guiding
principle so do you take the unification
of couplings
i think you answered this but just to to
make sure that i didn't misunderstand
do you take that as good motivation for
thinking that if we
do keep pressing on to higher energies
either at the large hadron collider
at a new accelerator we still have good
reason to believe
we'll find some new particles yes yeah i
still i'm i'm a uh
uh super symmetry look die hard
i i think uh uh yeah i
i so i i would be full of hope
of course it's easy for me to spend
other people's money but uh yeah
it would be i i would be pretty hopeful
about that well in a similar vein i'm
hopeful about
pressing uh proton decay experiments
harder because
the existing constraints are just kind
of
at the edge of compatibility with
unification ideas and
a little harder pressing might might get
us there
so uh so if i were a young
experimentalist
neither of which is true but if i
i would not be discouraged i i i think
uh there are and if i wanted to make a
an impact in fundamental physics i don't
i think it's not
uh out of the question that there'd be
breakthrough on either of those fronts
and either of them would be very rich
right if proton decay is discovered
there would be
many many follow-up studies of how it
decays what it decays into
is it cp violating blah blah blah and
then and similarly certainly if
supersymmetry is found that'd be
zillions of
new particles and phenomena to study
we'd get be able to get a much more
detailed picture
of how unification works uh it's very
mysterious
exactly how super symmetry gets
spontaneously broken
so that would be a real gold line of of
information and also
really would would bring the prospects
of making contact between making
detailed contact between quantum
mechanics and gravity much closer
yeah that's certainly true and but there
does seem to be the possibility just to
play devil's advocate here
as a as a middle-aged theoretical
physicist um
yeah uh that we don't find anything
right i mean that we don't find dark
matter directly that we don't find new
particles at the lhc
and then what what in your mind is the
best strategy for moving forward if
that's what happened
well we've we've had kind of a uh
several decade experiment alone along
along these lines
uh and well there are several
possible reactions one is to
try to push aesthetic
considerations of uh how
uh sort of sort of how an ultimately
unified theory might
should look and uh this leads us into
super string theory is probably the most
ambitious and and
uh accomplished of those attempts
uh that so that's one uh
one attitude another attitude
is to try to help the experimentalists
make
new kinds of experiments that uh give
will give
further guidance to sort out lhc's
uh signals better or just or
astrophysical
consequences of unified theories or uh
ex we did better experiments to look for
axions and dark matter
there there are a whole variety of
different experimental
quasi-phenomenological uh approaches to
improving the fundamental laws
uh and then there's another alternative
which says
no do something else no one no one puts
a gun to your head and says you have to
work on quantum gravity
or you you have to try to improve the
core theory
there are great problems having to do
with uh
applications of the physics we've
understood which maybe sounds less
glamorous but is every bit as glamorous
and rewarding and fundamental in the
good sense
uh and or you know they're
i mean they're problems like
understanding how mind emerges from
matter
there are many many other things you can
do that are entertaining and useful to
mankind
and rewarding so if fundamental physics
seems
too arid to you or
then do something else right
you know my own idiosyncratic minority
view is that
we there's still a lot to be learned by
thinking about the foundations of
quantum mechanics i think that you know
we we have not really mastered that yet
which is a bit of an embarrassment
yes and well and that that has become to
me
a uh a much more attractive
thing to do now uh because the
technology of looking
at the really basic processes of quantum
mechanics where you probe
consequences of entanglement and
superposition
and and of course now the prospect of
quantum information processing
has made these formally uh
kind of uh academic questions that were
divorced from experimental
and technological practice uh now they
are
at the forefront of uh experimental and
technological
uh exploration and and the questions get
posed in
really new ways that to me are much
richer than than
you know philosophical discussions of uh
the measurement problem or you know
which is
notorious i always used to warn students
away from
and still do uh i've worn them
but but in this in this new form of
uh you know real real real questions
that arise
in in practice and real opportunities i
think
the same sort of questions uh arises
much more fruitfully i guess an
operational way of putting it is
given that we haven't yet seen new
particles at the large hadron collider
we haven't yet seen dark matter
uh how much of our effort should be in
sort of taking a step back and saying
well maybe it's just
quantum field theory is not the right
paradigm to think about things for
moving forward or something even deeper
well that could be but but uh how should
i
saying uh maybe this is all wrong
sometimes
it doesn't tell you what to do when you
wake up in the morning
and we've discussed previously that the
tremendous
success of uh our core theories
and so if something else is going on at
a deeper level it has
the first job has to be to explain
why the the framework of quantum field
theory
looks so good right and well okay maybe
that
can be done but but but uh
yeah that i mean that's what you have to
that's what you're up against
and uh what i thought you were going to
say
was uh
that if you don't if you're not
uh optimistic about finding new
elementary particles or new phenomena in
at accelerators
to think about uh other worlds
that uh that can be realized in the
laboratory
to me what suddenly it's kind of a
realization that that
an epiphany that i had sort of
subconsciously for many years
but just uh came to me when i
was thinking sort of philosophically in
connection with the book and
which is that every material defines a
world in itself
you know you can imagine yourself living
inside that material
and nowadays with strong ai there are
even ideas about how certain kinds of
materials
intelligences could live and the laws
would look quite different
and the particles would be quite
different and
that to me gives a whole new dimension
to the idea of the issues of what's
fundamental and what are fundamental
particles and so forth so i was really
uh ecstatic
in the last few months in the midst of
the covet and all a tremendous
bright spot has been finally
the observation of anions the clear
observation
of things that are not bosons and not
fermions that we've been playing with
for almost 40 years now
uh and now there's beautiful
experiments that show the behavior
and that's also
that happened because a lot more
attention has been focused on these
things because of their
potential uh use in quantum technology
so so that's that's to me a beautiful
example of
uh how physics grows and and
the questions that are its most fruitful
focus
uh change over time i mean this is this
is i think something that
it will be worth we should do this a
little bit more justice because it's a
different way of thinking that i think a
lot of people
aren't familiar with like everyone knows
you can go look for new particles that
you haven't found
everyone knows these days that there
could be
other universes out there cosmologically
very very far away but
but this idea that you can make a
material and
essentially conjure into existence
effectively new laws of physics in that
material
explain that a little bit more because
people are less familiar with that yeah
well i
uh i like to talk about uh quasi worlds
there's a uh there's a concept that's
that's
come to dominate our understanding of
matter at the quantum level called quasi
particles
and uh what quasi particles are
are concentrations of energy that behave
like particles
inside but inside materials and they can
have quite different par
properties from the particles outside of
materials
i mean for instance one example that's
changed the world
is inside uh semiconductors the
particles that carry positive charge
which are called holes usually
uh can have a quite a small mass much
smaller than the mass of the proton
more comparable to the mass of the
electron and
or even smaller and this makes it
possible to manipulate
charge create charge and and use it
in ways that are practical
and very versatile and this is what led
to the discovery of the transistor
similarly and the the properties of
superconductors we can understand as
photons getting a mass
inside the superconductor so the
particles
the behavior of particles inside matter
can be quite different from outside
matter you can also have
qualitatively different emergent kind of
phenomena
so quasi particles are a very popular
concept
but even if you if you take away the
particles and think about
what they're embedded in that's a quasi
world it's a
it's a world with its own particles its
own laws of physics
and each one of them deserves to be
given its
respect right just and and that's to me
has been a
an epiphany as i said and and really
uh a wonderful stimulus to imagination
what would it be
like to live in these worlds uh what
what could you do
to uh what you know what sort of
questions would you ask how
strange would the world we ordinarily
experience an empty space
look uh so uh yeah so that that
that's another example of of uh
chain uh evolving the meaning of what it
means to be fundamental what it means to
uh understand things and just to to have
fun
and use your imagination and just to be
clear these are not
purely imaginative these are things that
are technologically explorable
oh yeah absolutely and and and by
imagining worlds that have wonderful
properties wonderful possibilities you
can then
help you know uh help experimentalists
to uh do new things
uh explore these possibilities so yeah
it's it's uh how should i say if if
you're frustrated with high-energy
accelerators
if you're willing to go to a quasi world
then the energies don't have to be so
high
and you can have experiments which take
on the
in favorable cases on the time scale of
days rather than
than uh years or decades uh
sometimes as i said with anyone's it did
take decades
but uh but at least it's happened
and uh yeah so uh
and and it also just to complete the
circle on this
uh it raises also
a question which is whether our world
should be considered as a quasi world
so i knew you're going to go there yeah
so uh
so that as we've discussed the laws
that we actually observe are very much
conditioned uh
by condensates and spontaneous symmetry
breaking
we know that often in physics when
symmetries break they can break in
different ways
and also that materials for instance
that define worlds
can also be layers within materials that
within different materials or uh or be
riddled with impurities or
uh so it raises questions about whether
our world can be fruitfully considered
yeah as
a representative of a much wider class
or something that's embedded in a larger
uh scheme and even the question of
whether
of what kinds of defects there might be
that
uh would reveal that kind of possibility
so so i i love this idea of quad
extending quasi particles to quasi
worlds
yeah it means to me they're both it's
not it's not even speculative i mean
it's
it's it's or i should say it's not
purely speculative
it has many contacts with reality with
uh real experiments
and with technology and and not
exotic technology the understanding of
quasi particles was
absolutely basic to microelectronics and
the kind of thing that makes it possible
for you and me
to be speaking right now in very
different locations and recording it
and sharing it eventually with many
other people
that all comes from basic quantum
mechanics and
understanding quasi particles and
semiconductors
everyone wants to keep their home and
family safe whether it's from a break-in
a fire flood or medical emergency
simplisafe home security delivers
award-winning 24 7 protection
they've got your back day and night
ready to send police fire or
emts when you need them most straight to
your door
simply safe has an arsenal of sensors
and cameras to protect every inch of
your home
and the best part of it is it's so
simple to set up the whole thing takes
about 30 minutes
there's no reason to be intimidated by a
whole bunch of equipment
then simply safes professionals take
over monitoring your house 24 7
and ready to send help the moment
there's an alarm
with simply safe there's no long-term
contract
no hidden fees or installation costs and
right now
mindscape listeners get a free home
security camera
when you purchase a simply safe system
at simplysafe.com
mindscape there's also a 60-day
risk-free trial so there's nothing to
lose
visit simplysafe.com mindscape for your
free security camera today
that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash mindscape
i i've done recent podcasts both with uh
nick bostrom who is famous for the
simulation argument
and with your mit colleague uh max
tegmark who thinks that all possible
universes
exist uh i mean is it even in your mind
worth thinking about this question of uh
like is our universe part of some way
bigger structure
uh oh it's worth thinking about yeah but
it doesn't take much thought to
discredit it in my opinion
the uh uh the laws that we observe
just don't look like a competently
programmed
simulation in what sense they don't
well they i guess most profoundly they
have a lot of hidden complexity
so when you dig deeper you find that
there's hidden structure that's not used
for anything
why would you do that if you're
simulating a world
also the laws are very constrained
they're local
they don't change in time they don't
change in place uh
in a programmed environment there's no
reason to to obey any of those
constraints
and you know people who build computer
games typically trash them all
so yeah why yeah so it just doesn't look
that way and then there's the
embarrassing question of okay if this is
a simulated world
what what is what is the thing in which
it's simulated
made out of what are the laws for that
yeah what
i mean yeah so so it begs the question
and then when you think about it
uh you put off that question which is
but
if you even think about it coherently it
just doesn't seem
at all likely now a very different
question is whether it's logically
possible
and i do think it's logically possible
and i think it may even be the future
i think uh i i like to say that uh
natural intelligence is a special case
of artificial intelligence
because i think we
understand the laws well enough and to
say that we can make sufficiently
complicated structures
that that can carry out intelligent
operations i mean we
we make computers that do fantastically
difficult things and play chess better
than i can or anyone can
and so forth uh that
they uh and uh so there's every reason
to think that intelligence can be
embodied
materially and furthermore that uh
within our brains the
uh people have studied how the nervous
system works in great detail how signals
are transmitted uh and never had to get
beyond
the framework of the laws of physics
that we know
on the contrary there are very many
non-trivial applications of the laws of
physics
into designing instruments that probe
the brain and also to making models of
what's going on
inside the brain now our understanding
is far from complete
but so far there's been no need
despite tremendous amounts of research
some of it very delicate to change the
laws of physics
so for instance to think if there was a
power of mind that was separate from the
laws of physics
you would expect that we'd have to
somehow shield delicate experiments from
that power of mind but that's never been
true yeah i mean
you have to shield from vibration and
temperature variation and all kinds of
things but not
worry you don't never worry about what
the guy in the next office is thinking
so uh and that hasn't been necessary it
might have been necessary but it's not
necessary but
in fact it's not the the uh uh
so so there's every reason to think i th
that every reason to believe even if
it's not fully established
that mind as we know it emerges from
matter
and that we know the matter the laws of
matter sufficiently well
to stimulate them on a computer so that
we should be able to in principle
uh simulate the operation of the mind
of a brain on a computer so
in that sense i think it's hard to avoid
the conclusion if you think hard about
it
that natural intelligence is a special
case
of artificial intelligence and that
means
that you can imagine
producing human level or better
uh intelligence within a
computer of some kind it's a
quantitative question
how fast and big the computer has to be
maybe it has to be a quantum computer
but in principle it is and and and then
you could imagine
uh intelligences that live in a
simulated universe
so that they are not experiencing the
external world as we know it but
just a stream of data that's in inside
this machine
uh so i think it's logically possible
but
i don't think our that i don't think
that i work that way and i don't think
our world that works that way
because the the way our world works
would
doesn't conform to reasonably to any
kind of reasonable programming practice
it's too constrained and too wasteful of
resources on hidden complexity
i think i'm on your side as far as our
world is concerned but the
the ev the argument for the simulation
argument
at least bears a family resemblance to
arguments that are used in cosmology
with the multiverse and the anthropic
principle and so forth and if i'm
if i'm remembering correctly you are you
are sympathetic to that kind of
reasoning whereas i know that some of
our colleagues think that
you're just giving up on science
entirely if you invoke a cosmological
multiverse
oh no no i i think it's it's not only a
logical possibility but in some
form uh it's it's true
yeah i mean i don't want to get into the
technical details but
uh if you believe in actions which i do
and you believe in inflation which i do
and if you believe that uh inflation
occurred after the peche quinn
transition
then different parts of uh the
post-inflationary universe
what we would call a multiverse uh have
different vastly different amounts of
dark matter in the form of axions
and so they have significantly different
physical behavior
so you can construct very concrete
models that
are models that we use for good reasons
in other contexts that do embody a
multiverse
and so i so i better not have a
prejudice against it because i work with
those models all the time that so
they're logically possible
uh and i think very natural uh
i they are however sort of let me say
epistemologically dangerous because
they encouraged giving up
when you if you know
theoretical physics and especially
fundamental physics can be very
difficult you ask
because we know so much as we discussed
earlier
it's very hard to make improvements and
we look for aesthetic flaws we look for
loose ends of which there are plenty
but it's been very difficult to make
improvements uh and
uh one way to say one way to get off the
hook so to speak
and say well why aren't you improving
the laws of physics is to say
well it's not because i lack cleverness
it's because
it's impossible it's because different
laws of physics are realized in
different places
and it's just an accident which ones we
happen to observe here
okay so maybe that's right but it's too
easy
yeah it's much too easy and uh
yeah so it uh that that's that's the
epistemological danger i would say
now you know if of course if there is a
multi-unit multiverse with enough
uh loose ends so to speak so the laws do
change drastically not just in the
amount of dark matter but in many ways
from place to place then in fact it's
going to be impossible to improve
the standard model or the core in in
in uh to the bitter end so to speak
because some of it will be accidental
but i think it's way premature to uh
to give up on that way premature
and it's too easy uh it lets people off
the hook
so uh yeah well it brings us to the fact
that
you know it's not my fault that i can't
do better it's god's fault yeah and
no i don't that's that i don't like that
well some of this worry has come out of
of string theory right many of our
colleagues for the last several decades
have have
pointed to string theory as the most
promising way forward
as far as i know you have not done a lot
of work directly on unconventional
string theory what is your what is your
feeling about that approach to moving
beyond uh
quantum field theory well i i think it
has
uh produced a lot of attractive work
that's intellectually rich and has spun
off into fertile
mathematics but i
don't see that it's been converging
towards
informative assertions about the
physical world
well it's very elegantly stated actually
yes you can check
uh um i for me personally
uh you know i've kind of voted with my
feet i think they're
more promising things to think about for
me that's partially a sociological
statement but i think it's
string theory is getting plenty of
attention it doesn't need me
and so so i i'm happy you're doing
things that other people
aren't doing and uh the the the
but that's a personal statement there's
a and
uh so far i haven't regretted my choice
uh but i watch with people i watch the
subject and i watch what people are
doing and
and i wish them good luck and if if and
when
things that i think are promising
insights into the physical world emerge
i will
you know pay a lot of attention and
yeah do you think that the rest of the
field has voted with their feet in a in
a slightly too uniform way do you think
that too much of our intellectual effort
is going in that particular direction
uh i do but
but i might i might be wrong so i don't
want to discourage you know
plenty of people are doing other things
so it's not as if
uh they the you know
the rest of the world is feeling the
lack of uh
input from people who are working on
string theory it's fine people can work
on
string theory and it doesn't hurt
anything uh
i feel well it's going to i don't want
to be patronizing people
the people who do it are mostly adults
and they know what they're doing
but students and people who are thinking
about what they're gonna do
should go into it with open eyes right
okay they
they should realize that uh the prospect
of making an impact in
uh our understanding of empirical
science
or technology are not you the prospect
that you'll make
impact like that is probably not
optimized by going into string theory
yeah no actually i think that uh we're
in exact alignment here i mean i i feel
a need to defend the string theory
against unfair criticisms but
but i do worry a little bit about the
fact that uh
it it seems hard these days to connect
it directly to empirical reality
yeah uh well not you know some nice
ideas are coming off as
coming out as spin-offs very very clever
people do string theory and they do
clever things
so there's been a lot as i said there's
been a lot of
fruitful mathematics uh there have been
new techniques that have proved
uh somewhat useful
in uh in condensed matter although you
know
certainly not proportional to the amount
of effort that's gone into it
but uh the so and you know and
and the future may look different i mean
there may be real breakthroughs that
come out of string theory that wouldn't
have come otherwise
uh but uh but
you know so far uh the amount
i would say i you know other people may
disagree
and i might get uh be very unpopular
among some of my colleagues for saying
this but i think
uh the output compared to the input
has been pretty disappointing on the
empirical side
you have been involved in productive
ways on the black hole information
problem which a lot of strength
theorists
care about uh what what is your feeling
these days because i just did a
a wonderful podcast with neda engelhardt
and other of your mit colleagues uh what
what is your current feeling on the
state of that problem do you think we're
making real progress
i think progress is being made in the
sense that uh
more intellectually coherent
uh pictures are being drawn and
some surprising connections to
uh error correction and kind of really
you know uh interesting new
chapters of quantum theory are emerging
uh on the other hand you know it is
when you it is a very esoteric problem
nobody nobody is going to produce i i
mean i don't see a way but
who knows but no nobody has produced
an experimental system to which these
ideas apply
in any reasonably direct way uh
so you know i what does it mean to solve
a problem like that i'm not even sure
what it means
where you you can't check you know many
uh many hypotheses go into it
the the uh the distance between the
models
and actual black holes that or phenomena
you can observe are vast and many things
could go wrong along the way
in making these models so i i i guess
yeah it's wonderful that people are
making progress
they feel they're making progress and
have
a literature that they enjoy and
and is is uh it and it really is
interesting from any point of view
yeah it's good uh
and maybe i should leave it at that yeah
but okay i don't how should i say i
don't think
it's i don't think it's the pinnacle of
physics let me put it down let me
put it that way well it's
it's a i think that's a perfectly good
um attitude in the sense that like you
say
we we have this enormously successful
set of ideas in the core theory etc
and unlike the 1960s where there are
these big puzzles given to us by the
data
it's harder to figure out uh where to
best put our intellectual efforts
and um yeah they're it's hard to judge
what the good work is
sometimes right like is it just what the
smart people say because
no one is predicting a new experimental
result at the moment well i did
particularly antions in materials sure
that's
the point of course that was a long time
ago but but also you know as well
other things happen time crystals and so
they um
uh but and uh you know i
people vote with their feet so i'm for
instance i'm spending a lot of time now
uh really working with uh uh
experim uh with experimentalists and
even engineer quasi engineers to
design uh better axion detectors
so that's and that's a an activity that
is v it calls on very different kinds of
expertise it's really fun
and you know well the chance that we'll
succeed of course is not
enormous but it's not zero either and
uh that's that's one
reaction is to try try to devise new
kinds of experiments to think about
uh other worlds in the sense that we
talked about before there are many
creative things you can be doing right
and i think you know i think it's
wonderful that people do different
things
well let me let me make a terrible
confession here because you've done so
many interesting things that i
completely forgot about the time
crystals
why don't you tell us a little bit about
time crystals what they are and what the
state of the art is there
yeah well uh i guess the best
non-technical way to describe it
is to say that well maybe i should stop
step back a little what is a crystal
exactly a crystal is a uh an arrangement
of atoms in a regular system from up
from the point of view of
uh basic description fundamental physics
if you like
is an arrangement of atoms in a definite
pattern in space
that is not fully translation invariant
in the sense that
if you move it a little bit it's not
quite the same thing but if you move it
by a finite amount
it becomes the same thing if you
translate it so that one atom goes into
the next atom
uh and uh we're accustomed in physics to
making analogies between space and time
these days i mean they're just
we use any of the same concepts for both
they're continuous dimensions
so uh so uh uh
it's natural to ask and uh i raised this
question in a serious way in
2012 whether uh whether you can have
materials that are like
crystals but in time so
this of course wouldn't be atoms that
come to exist and pass away
but it could be some kind of phenomena
some kind of march marker
that spontaneously arises
within physical physical system that uh
has less than full time symmetry and and
so
some something that doesn't settle down
in a normal way
into a boring equilibrium but somehow
in its preferred ground state or
maybe you have to generalize the
definition of ground state slightly
into uh into something that has
non-trivial behavior in time and
this was very controversial when i when
i uh
first proposed it but now some beautiful
experiments
have uh discovered this phenomena in a
very convincing way
and it's become a thriving field and
another way to phrase it that's more
colloquial is to say that these are
materials that
spontaneously form clocks yeah
they uh they're they're sort of it's
like uh
it's like the blind watchmaker but
you find these clocks that are lying
around
under the right circumstance if you find
the right material and
at the right at low temperatures and
this and that and maybe you have to
sculpt it a little
that that it forms a clock with very
little prodding
uh and uh that so that's basically what
a time crystal is
uh there are many variants but that's
that's the basic idea and the basic hope
for the field i think there are many
hopes because it's a whole new kind of
states of matter uh but to me
one very tangible possibility that would
be extremely
important is if uh these kinds of ideas
about things that form clocks
spontaneously
would let us build better clocks
forming accurate clocks is a frontier of
physics
as you probably know people are working
very hard and constantly trying to push
the uh the accuracy of clocks
because they're very useful it may seem
absurd for instance to try to get clocks
that
would lose one second over the whole
lifetime of the universe
but that's the frontier right now and
it's very valuable to have those things
because it allows you to look for
very small effects like the effect of
passing gravitational waves for
scientific purposes so if a clock slows
down a little bit due to
a passing disturbance in the
gravitational field you can you could
hope to sense it uh but another another
use is in gps like systems
because small errors in measurements of
time
translate into much larger errors
in estimates of distance because just
because the speed of light is so big
so that's what so getting uh
accurate cheap clocks
is definitely is a is a frontier of
physics that's very very important and
i'm hoping that
thinking about time crystals and maybe
some kind of hybrid between a time
crystal
and atomic clocks would allow us to push
the frontier of accurate time clipping
time keeping uh further well this has
been great i think you've been giving us
a lot of inspiration
and evidence for the idea that
fundamental physics is in an exciting
phase there's a lot of good questions uh
that we're struggling with and we're
going to learn a lot in the years to
come
yeah including including what
fundamental means
uh to me uh
and time crystals was a good example of
this uh
the the meaning of words evolves and
sometimes the most fruitful meaning of a
word
emerges from its use we find out what
the
uh energy was like that uh
and the i think as physics advances and
we
conquer more and more new frontiers of
knowledge
uh what we regard as as it's as
fundamental advances and fundamental
questions will also evolve
and it's a never-ending frontier that's
as far as i can tell yeah
that's what makes it fun to me so frank
wilcheck thanks so much for being on the
moneystay podcast
okay thank you very much sean
[Music]
you